do you know that the
the bat lady dr she was working with dr
peter
dozick and they were working on gain of
function research genetically modifying
manipulating
viruses to make them stronger more
deadly more contagious
i think we need to have a serious
investigation and it should be
bipartisan but unfortunately
the democrats don't seem to be very
interested in this
that's right house republicans demanding
answers after releasing
their report yesterday on the origins of
kovan 19. their bombshell findings first
obtained by fox news
makes the most detailed case yet in
support of a
lab leak but despite this all
network and major cable news outlets
except us
ignored the story here to react fox news
contributor and media opinion columnist
for the hill joe concha
joe good morning good morning steve how
are you
i'm doing okay thank you very much for a
very busy tuesday
why is it that the mainstream media
and democrats don't seem to be curious
about
this virus that has killed millions of
people around the world
well steve a few reasons for one the
media doesn't cover it because it serves
as a reminder that when they rush to
judgment because as a republican like
senator tom cotton
who said that this can come from a lad
that being coveted or when president
trump
echoed the same thing they were
portrayed as reckless conspiracy
theorists and when you think about it
coming to that conclusion must have been
really hard unless you know you're
partisan
in trying to push a narrative because
there were barely any boots on the
ground in china
wall street journal washington post new
york times all had
journalists expelled from china at the
onset the very beginning of that
pandemic so it was impossible to verify
anything or get answers
and look finding the origins of this
virus that has killed what 4.2 million
people worldwide
more than 618 000 people here it's the
most important investigation
we can do of our lifetimes because we
don't learn how this happens steve
we are absolutely condemned to repeat it
sure and you look at some of the
headlines from some of the mainstream
outlets from last year
cnn march of last year their headline
was lab leak
coveted 19 theory is like something out
of a comic book
their virologist says forbes may of 2021
no science clearly shows that cobin 19
wasn't leaked from a lab
and reuters of 2020 said china lab
says conspiracy theories hurting efforts
to curb
virus whose side are they on
and you only have finite you know space
on the screen so you couldn't fit the
dozens
of other headlines that we saw from the
new york times in washington post
and other outlets and remember up until
earlier this summer steve
facebook would suppress censor any posts
about covid originating in a lab
in wuhan china why is that the job of a
social media giant like that
and many in the media and democratic
party called it misinformation now
suddenly it's a real possibility
even democrats are conceding that even
though they won't go ahead with an
investigation
so look here's the bottom line poll
after poll after poll
shows that trust in media confidence in
media is at such a low
here are your bottom three entities all
right your top two are small businesses
and military in terms of public
confidence yeah good even police
have a majority of support you got to go
to the bottom congress at 12
broadcast media at 16 newspapers at 21
i wonder why that is steve exactly and
joe when i say whose side are they on
it's like
when i went to journalism school it's
just tell me what
tell the folks exactly what is known
don't put a political spin on it
to suit for you know some other cause
rock chalk steve that's all i have to
say about where you went to school the
william ellen white school of journalism
at the kansas university is a good one
indeed all right good for you thank you
joe have a good day